hey reject nation Greg train with the J
buzz machine Jay Busbee
we're gonna watch a patron video request
Kent McKnight our beautiful sexy man
from Australia with a smile that died
for our top pledge on patreon currently
right here and one of the our reward
tiers on patreon is we have a video you
request we must definitely do Hugh
Jackman so the first video he requested
was an hour long and I was like whoa
buddy buddy buddy
and then he requested something else
he's like well I prefer this one and
it's a video that I've seen before for
sure many years ago many years ago God
must have been like 17 or something we
shot this Denny's fight scene my brother
uploaded this on his jab eco a channel
in 2014 but boy did we shoot this way
before that and I'll give us some
backstory behind this that I briefly
remember Denny's goofy fight scene with
Greg Alba bye jabby coalition this buddy
I have the many countless videos let's
see there's gonna be current order for
me to revisit but hey I'm gonna love it
though skinny little twerk back then
hey that's my car now yeah looks just as
good a dude's named Wayne is a
professional Taekwondo artist and you've
competed like on ESPN Wow there I am so
long they're all named Anthony I wonder
why
[Laughter]
[Music]
now young or miss you buddy
ha I can still kill anybody take a
little better
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh right broke his back Bain style ah my
thing hasn't gotten any better I don't
know
watch our sketches it's great dialogue
hey he tripped this down
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
physical comedy people slap some
teaching classes this Saturday at the
North Hollywood Rose Leader Steny
started all little kids and Teddy's ever
- is my way
[Music]
what
yes or two
[Music]
girl's name is Monica
[Music]
you'll never owned any what is that Jo
her crop was I was a was a Catholic boy
back in the day thanks for requesting
this kid
[Music]
[Music]
all right G take us behind the scenes
mammal wasn't like preparing for this
Magnum oh Anthony was javi movie yeah oh
no don't pull back the curtain on this
information the censor beep there javi
Kawai woke me up incredibly early in the
morning you know you know that lives in
the building next door you know how he
just like just shows up even though we
have like the exact same channel and he
doesn't care to give you a heads-up all
right G take us behind the scenes man
what was it like preparing for this
Magnum Jabby
movie don't pull back the curtain
incredibly early in the morning you know
that lives in the building next door you
know how he just like just shows up even
though we have like the exact same
channel he doesn't care to give you a
heads up I have a script watching to
choreograph stuff so choreographed that
morning four of us javi
this guy named Wayne and young me and I
did helpful out with a lot of the
choreography I did I was fond javi is a
not a loose director back then 70 takes
yeah everything's he got it he got it
could be a little intense on set
everyone cried maybe he's changed in
last 10 years I haven't I haven't been
in front of a camera with him directing
in the long time laughs yeah now he's
chill I got hurt cuz Wayne didn't do
like fight choreography oh because he
was a professional fighter so he really
wanted to kiss her and time I blocked
really painful that guy where is he now
is he still doing it is he still
fighting the good fight I don't know I
don't know what the guys been up to
I remember one story about Wayne that
I'm gonna share here publicly oh good
because we were like 16 or 17 when we
made this yeah yeah then him and his
buddy wanted to make a short film and
they're like I heard you rike and you
write her right for me and I said sure
so they gave me some basic idea of
something that I honestly can't remember
for the life of me then I wrote
something up I gave it to him and then
his partner three-way called me and then
they're like yeah this is not the
direction we're just looking for so yeah
probably all right
and they didn't hang up and the guy was
time Wayne dude why do you have to be
like it's group is good and I'm like
he's like I didn't want to be like a
dick about it he's like yeah but you're
never like it's like try to kiss his ass
and hang on what you know he's like why
do you want to say it script is [ __ ]
it's like it's all teary and I just was
like I would have said something now
yeah a 16 17 year old Greg was a little
bit more timid when it came to things
like that
how are you Wayne you're watching this
video buddy how's it going how's it
going that's short film come out you're
naked yes in like 12 years do it you
want a new draft yeah you know we can
try again
no don't worry about writing hasn't
gotten any better nor is my acting I'm
just as over the top 0% seen any of the
sketch Warner presented the same style
well Kent that was fun to revisit got
our visits from childhood trauma woken
up abruptly and forced to say insulted
about your own work that you
I mean they're idiots this year checked
check to make sure I was on the line
anymore you know there's like hey
Wayne's working on this you should hit
him up and I'm like no do you know what
he said 12 years ago I'm sure he's the
exact same human being and has never
changed yeah I have it if he wants to
call and apologize to me he knows where
to find me he doesn't even know I heard
it but and I expect him to know even
though I know he doesn't subscribe to
the real rejects notification bells
exist on every YouTube channel and check
us out on patreon full like TV show
reactions weekly Q&A is on Wayne I never
recovered over that trauma I never take
three-way calls anymore but I do three
nope I don't